it was quiet too quiet that had been
what everyone remembered about that day
ask any member of personnel who was
working what the one thing they recalled
before it happened it all tell you the
same that it had been too quiet and Erie
lull and the foundation's usual
day-to-day activity followed by Untold
unspeakable chaos but the quiet had come
first and within that quiet a Madman was
hiding his name was Vince Barrett at
least that was his legal name but he
much preferred to go by his online
moniker of the tainted lizard or just
the zard for short anyone who chooses to
call themselves something like that in
an attempt to sound cool might well be a
person to avoid and in Vince sorry the
zard's case that sentiment was accurate
he was a social recluse devoting a lot
of his time to some of the darker
corners of the internet and we don't
just mean that he spent his day days
trawling through Reddit no the zard's
interests were in the Paranormal the
unusual and inexplicable as well as the
community of his fellow internet
recluses dedicated to unearthing the
true Supernatural horrors of the world
eventually spending so much time in
corners of the online world where few
normal people would dare To Tread that
would lead to Zar becoming a member of
the prolific Forum known as parawatch
this was the real deal not just urban
legends and blurry photos of Bigfoot or
Faked handheld videos of people falling
into the back rooms perowatch had long
been known to and kept under the
surveillance of the SCP Foundation why
well because this Infamous online
Message Board would occasionally feature
posts about anomalies some even
including scps and leaked information
about the foundation themselves of
course hardly any of these posts stayed
up for very long before the foundation's
tech team scrubbed them permanently but
it was here on the parawatch Forum where
Vince Barrett would encounter a fateful
video clip acting fast he managed to
save the file before it was taken down
there was footage taken from the body
cam of a foundation security officer
during the midst of a containment breach
the zard had play his hands shaking with
excitement the original poster of the
clip to parowanche had said that this
footage was perhaps the only known video
on the entire internet that depicted
something known as
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile of
course those familiar with 682 and the
SCP Foundation will need no introduction
but Vince on the other hand had only
ever heard rumors about this creature
and now in the video playing on his
computer screen he was seeing it for the
first time the reptile was free from its
containment chamber tearing its way
through a foundation facility and making
quick work of dispatching the security
Personnel that dared to stand in its way
was a force of unbridled Carnage and
rage destroying anything in its path and
adapting to its environment deep in the
periwatch Forum the zard had read rumors
and leaks from alleged x foundation
staff and detractors that 682 was like
something out of a nightmare they said
that the creature could adapt perfectly
in response to damage inflicted upon it
or to changes in its environment as well
as heal any injury it sustained it
persisted it kept on going and something
about that enamored Vince to the
infamous anomaly he thought it was
beautiful the ultimate apex predator and
admired the hard to destroy reptile's
tenacity as well as its ferocity
watching the horrific Containment Breach
footage he realized then and there that
he was a devoted fanatic of scp-682 his
time on the dark side of the web had
twisted his mind and led him to make one
fateful decision that he needed to see
the creature in person that had been
almost a year earlier and in the time
since the tainted lizard had pulled on
every dark web string he knew of
eventually getting in contact with a
shady group called the chaos Insurgency
Vince had managed to get a hold of a
real life as CP Foundation key card as
well as the location of the facility
they were holding 682 in and a forged
transfer document posing as a humble
unassuming janitor the zard had made his
way inside the foundation and wasted no
time in making a beeline straight for
the acid tank where 682 was held he
stared at the creature through the glass
eyes wide and Jaws slacked in utter awe
of the Monstrous reptile perhaps the
biggest fan of scp-682 on the planet
couldn't quite believe he was standing
in the presence of the creature itself
it barely seemed to pay him any mind
from the other side of the tank the acid
surrounding it melting 682 as fast as it
could heal seeing it in containment
enraged fence he hated that the
foundation had kept what he viewed as a
perfect organism locked up after having
tried time and time again to destroy it
don't worry the czard murmured
approaching the tank well over the
minimum safe distance you're a force of
unparalleled destruction and you don't
deserve to be here I'm gonna set you
free unfortunately after the glass had
been smashed and the alarm screamed out
that another Containment Breach was
occurring Vince would quickly find out
that the reptilian Beast he revered so
highly didn't quite hold him in the same
regard if you thought the zard was going
to make it all the way through the story
alive well then we regret to inform you
that you're sorely mistaken although not
as woefully misguided as Vince himself
who was the first person in the path of
scp-682 when he freed the creature with
all those leaks and rumors on pairwatch
had failed to mention about the heart to
destroy reptile was its vehement and
Relentless hatred for all other forms of
life including its very own fan and the
tainted lizard was only the first
casualty of scp-682 latest Rampage but
this time was different sure 682 was
easily tearing its way through SCP
Foundation Personnel left and right
security teams were flung aside and
ripped to shreds as they tried in vain
to recontain the Monster research staff
found themselves tripping over each
other trying to rush out of the
destructive path of the hard to destroy
reptile only to find themselves the next
to face its ferocious attack in other
words it seemed to mostly be another
unbridled Slaughter common fare for an
scp-682 Containment Breach except rather
than Breaking its way out of the
facility this particular instance saw
the creature heading in the direction of
another anomaly
scp-914 better known as the Clockworks
now if a rampaging regenerative reptile
on the loose wasn't enough cause for
concern then seeing it moving along its
trajectory to another anomalous
refinement machine certainly was those
that had been on the other side of the
facility when the dearly Departed zard
set sic City to free we're now looking
on in horror as the hard to destroy
reptile burst into the room housing
scp-914 the foundation staff in the
midst of panic stared at security
monitors with baited breath palpable
fear hanging in the air each and every
one of them knew that scp-682 was more
than just a Mindless Beast the creature
was fiercely frighteningly intelligent
sentient even and as it approached the
controls for the Clockworks every
onlooker secretly hopes something or
someone would step in at the last second
and prevent scp-682 from entering the
machine unfortunately that's not what
happened
scp-914 word into life its gears and
Gyro spinning as scp-682 entered the
input booth now normally the way the
Clockworks operates is by destroying any
item placed within it and replacing it
with something else in the output Booth
depending on its setting it either
completely disintegrates an item breaks
down an object into its base components
replaces it with an equivalent or
improves it and being set to very fine
as it was right now
scp-914 can even add anomalous
properties to whatever is put inside of
it but what happens when an
indestructible and infinitely adaptable
monstrosity is in the Clockworks while
it can't destroy and recreate a better
version of something that would be known
for being hard to destroy can it the
entire machine was going haywire
scp-682 was adapting to the refinement
process refusing to let scp-914 unmake
it even to replace it with an improved
version of itself the hard to destroy
reptile and the Clockworks were at a
momentary stalemate and watched with
baited Breath by the foundation
scp-914 began to malfunction its
Clockwork components getting stuck as if
the machine was jammed its cogs were
clogged up unable to destroy the subject
in the input Booth the room round was
beginning to Shake in fact the very
ground was trembling at the force of the
whole machine shuddering enact the
abandoned all hope protocol the head of
research said desperately watching the
events unfold from the other side of the
building the site director looked at
them and nodded the pair of them
entering their secure passcodes to
activate this secretive security measure
just as they did a small earthquake
erupted underfoot the entire wing of the
facility housing the Clockworks and
scp-682 had collapsed into the ground a
huge crater was all that remained
littered with wreckage of a whole
portion of the foundation site along
with broken pieces of scp-914 for the
next few minutes everyone was on edge
secretly hoping that scp-682 hadn't
survived maybe the Clockworks had
managed to destroy it but the sheer
force of doing so had caused the machine
to collapse in on itself or perhaps the
hard to destroy reptile was now buried
beneath several thousand tons of debris
dead long last but the foundation staff
knew better than to get their hopes up
and sure enough just as an armed
security team approached the crater
something started stirring in the rubble
suddenly
scp-682 came bursting out of the crater
emerging in not quite the same state
although no less deadly than before the
Clockworks hadn't been able to unmake
the hard to destroy reptile but the
resultant malfunction and explosion had
imbued the creature with a whole host of
new anomalous abilities it still
resembled its old self but was now more
humanoid standing by Peter instead of on
all fours some of its body mass had
seemingly been reduced due to damage
sustained in the malfunction although
scp-682 was still plenty of feet taller
than an ordinary human being in fact it
could be any height it needed to be the
creature scaly skin seemed to be
shifting unnaturally moving of its own
accord like it was already preparing to
adapt to oncoming damage and as the
nearby security team were about to find
out this made it even deadlier than
before in a panic the foundation
officers opened fire only to find that
their weapons weren't operating the way
they should something caused excitation
of the copper shells of their bullets
making them either expand and block the
barrels of their guns or causing them to
backfire horribly injuring the security
Personnel wielding them before anybody
could even call an air support or heavy
artillery as a backup a number of the
foundation's most powerful weapons
suffered even more catastrophic misfires
missiles detonated early they hadn't
even been aimed at scp-682 yet but they
would have been instead they exploded
taking with them a huge number of
foundation entities some miles away from
where the newly refined reptile now
stood
scp-682's regenerative Powers had been
altered by the Clockworks it wasn't
purely reactive to oncoming damage now
it was preemptive it could adapt to
attacks that hadn't even happened yet
with no way of stopping it
scp-682 began decimating everything in
its path with greater ferocity than ever
over the coming days the newly dubbed
impossible to destroy reptile began its
biggest Rampage yet entering a permanent
rage State and unleashing destruction on
a global scale it stormed through cities
and wiped out entire major population
centers in moments it seemed nothing on
Earth could stand against the refined
reptile fueled by its singular mission
to wipe out all life in existence the
surviving Personnel of the SCP
Foundation soon came to learn that no
damage could be inflicted on the
creature whatsoever
scp-682 could predict attacks ahead of
the person that would carry it out and
then adapt changing the very world
around it so that attack never came the
impossible to destroy reptile's
adaptations usually took the form of
diverting any oncoming damage it
preempted it would take and instead
inflicted that same damage on whoever it
shows even though the machine had
malfunctioned the Clockworks had made
scp-682 that good at adapting to its
surroundings that the creature had
almost become a universal constant the
fact that it could not be harmed now
seemed to be as fundamental of a law as
that of gravity but that wasn't going to
stop the SCP Foundation from trying the
number of casualties the world over had
been increasing steadily day by day as
scp-682 continued its devastating
campaign of Slaughter some of the
remaining scraps of the foundation had
tried to subdue the creature but in the
attempts at fighting it with
Conventional Weapons were ill-advised to
say the least after all how do you fight
against a creature that can predict your
every move and counter them before
you've even thought of those moves well
you can try throwing something so
unexpected at it at least pulling
something out of left field means that
the chances of scp-682 seeing it coming
are slightly Slimmer and that was where
the abandon all hope protocol came in
you see the foundation had been
anticipating that 682 Would One Day
become too powerful to contain long
before the creature had gained its new
ability to preemptively adapt and while
the worldwide death toll had climbed
from hundreds of thousands of innocent
people to the earliest Millions an
unlikely counter-attack was brewing one
so unexpected that even the impossible
to destroy reptile would struggle to see
it coming just as Humanity was facing
the brink of Extinction the foundation
dispatched their last hope at stopping
scp-682 other scps the abandon all hope
protocol had been devised for when the
suffering and destruction caused by
scp-682 became so great that there were
no other options left when it had been
activated Foundation agents stationed at
various sites across the world had
gathered a specially selected group of
anomalies each one was chosen because
they were known to be sympathetic
towards Humanity or at least be coerced
into taking on
scp-682 and now these scps were stepping
up to the plate ready to fight the
impossible to destroy reptile or more
likely to die trying
scp-076-2 the immortal Warrior known as
Abel was Infamous for picking fights the
ancient Sumerian Swordsmen had a
penchant for seeking out the most
challenging adversaries so convincing
him to take a crack at scp-682 wasn't
all that difficult however rushing into
battle against the refined reptile Abel
quickly found he couldn't draw his
weapons from his pocket Dimension they
were dissipating the moment his fingers
touched them Vanishing faster than he
could draw no matter the warrior thought
he'd been alive for centuries and thus
had become a master in every form of
hand-to-hand combat as you can imagine
he didn't last very long left to slowly
revive inside his Stone tomb after
scp-682 had finished dispatching him
Abel's brother Kane incurred a slightly
different result when he went Toe to Toe
with the impossible to destroy reptile
scp-073 was hardly the fighter his
brother was but had the anomalous trait
of reflecting incoming damage back at
whoever was inflicting it on him so when
scp-682 attacked Kane theoretically the
same attack would have bounced back and
harmed the reptile itself and before
that's what would have happened but now
scp-682 could adapt preemptively a
strange never before seen phenomenon
occurred it appeared that neither
scp-073 nor the refined reptile were
harming each other at all however on a
metaphysical level the potential damage
of 682's attacks against Kane were being
reflected back towards the reptile only
for the creature to preemptively adapt
to the damage from its own attack being
inflicted back what resulted was a
feedback loop of Perpetual possible
damage that ended only when Kane
eventually passed out from shock
unfortunately while he could reflect
damage back at an attacker he felt the
pain of every hit and scp-682 had more
than just a mean right hook the
foundation had hoped given its 100
mortality record that scp-096 would have
no trouble killing the impossible to
destroy reptile or at the very least
harming it enough so that it could be
subdued after all 682 still needed to
see and anyone looking at the shotgun
quickly met their end but when the tall
pale humanoid approached
scp-682 something unusual happened the
reptile could look at scp-096 able to
see it perfectly perhaps the creature's
adaptive properties were creating an
intentional blind spot in its Vision
removing scp-096 from view or maybe 682
no longer saw with just eyes receiving
the world in a manner far beyond our
understanding of basic sight but
whatever the case the impossible to
destroy reptile made scp-096 turn and
flee in
compelled to put an end to the reptile's
reign of terror
scp-4494 the Specter manifested nearby
and tried to intervene the result was
nothing short of brutal a one-sided find
that not even the living embodiment of
crime fighting could hope to win after
scp-682 had finished off the Specter a
strange black fluid began oozing from
nearby although one of the hardest to
Wrangle the foundation believed that
they had convinced scp-106 to Aid in
taking down
scp-682 the old man emerged from the
oily secretion shuffling menacingly
towards the impossible to destroy
reptile it seemed to freeze as if it was
taking a defensive stance against the
old man either that or tricking him into
getting closer before he could even
reach out a decrepit hand to touch the
reptile's shifting skin
scp-106 was suddenly coded in copious
amounts of the black substance he
secreted it coded him like thick tar the
more his decaying body produced the more
he was covered in it normally he was
resistant to the corrosive burning
effects of this substance however
scp-682's preemptive adaptation Powers
had caused scp-106 to overproduce the
oily substance enough to rapidly
dissolve the old man into a steaming
black puddle it was at this point that
scp-343 colloquially known as God
lowered his newspaper and looked out of
his window that is to say he looked out
of the huge hole that had been left in
the wall of his cell being omniscient as
cp343 was already burdened with the
awareness of what had happened
scp-682 had been refined into an even
worse version of itself by the
Clockworks up until now God had been
happy to avoid all the fighting and just
see how everything worked out but as
much as he tried to distract himself
scp-682 slaughtering other scps and
droves was getting in the way of his
reading oh this again in the Split
Second the the entire universe had been
unmade and then remade Almost exactly
the same except scp-343 had made a
slight adjustment giving a little nudge
to cause and effect in a few places as a
result a certain misguided form user had
never and would never infiltrate the
foundation and break
scp-682 free leading to the hard to
destroy reptile being refined by the
Clockworks although while it had been
unceremoniously returned to its original
form and placed back in its acid tank
scp-682 could still remember the power
it had wielded only moments before
everything had been Rewritten all it
needed was another chance to get into
the Clockworks now go check out scp-682
craziest mutations and adaptations and
what if the flesh that hates was put
inside scp-914 for more mutational
craziness